FEMALE SPEAKER: Norman Winarsky
is a venture adviser, lecturer,
author, and angel investor.
He is past president
of SRI ventures
at SRI International, a
world-leading research
institute founded by
Stanford University in 1946.
He was a co-founder
and board member
of Siri, which was spun out
from SRI in January, 2008
and acquired by
Apple in April, 2010.
Norman works with entrepreneurs,
startups, research institutes,
and major companies to
create breakthrough ventures
or products.
He is an author, a leader, a
lecturer, an Emmy Award winner,
and is here to speak to us
today about his new book,
"If You Really Want to
Change the World: A Guide
to Creating, Building,
and Sustaining
Breakthrough Ventures."
Welcome to Google, Norman.
NORMAN WINARSKY: Thank you.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
So this is a pleasure.
And first of all, it's a
pleasure to be here with you.
And those who are connecting,
I believe, are many, as well.
And I want you to feel
free to ask questions.
This is my guess is
an audience that's
particularly important, for
me at least, to want to reach,
and where I stand matters.
So is it better
over here, probably?
OK.
As long as I'm
not blocking that.
I particulaly want to reach
you because this book, which
is what this meeting,
this event is all about,
is not about creating
just any venture
and building and sustaining.
It's about
breakthrough ventures.
And so first question to you is
how many of you would actually
like to start a venture or
be part of a startup venture?
Could you raise your hands?
And what I define by
breakthrough venture
is one that will have an
impact on the world, one
that people's passion was so
important that they really
want to have a positive
benefit on millions of people.
That kind of venture,
how many people
would like to and have an
idea for that kind of venture
that they'd like to achieve?
So that's what this is about.
So that's what is distinguished.
If you look up on Amazon
something like entrepreneurship
or innovation or
something like that,
you'll get about
50,000 to 70,000 books.
That's not a good reason to
write a book in that space,
then, unless you really
have something you really
want to make a difference on.
So why did I write it?
First of all, I think
the story of Siri
not just a story about
how we created a company,
but it's about a process we
used to create that company,
and that was a process
that I wanted to share.
So the second is
that's the guide.
The process we've
done-- and by the way,
my coauthor's Henry Kressel.
He was a managing
director at Warburg Pincus
and helped create
many companies.
So the book is about our
experiences, about somewhere
between 10 and 20
companies that we've
helped create that had that
kind of breakthrough impact.
So remarkably, the kind of
impact, the kind of companies
that we've created,
they've not had
a new formula or a new flavor
for how we created them.
So what I'm really
telling you is information
that most great entrepreneurs
and most great venture
capitalists would
consider already
having been part
of their approach.
This is not the next great
flavor or the next great diet
on how to create ventures.
This is about how
our experiences been
over several decades
and dozens of companies
and what it took to create
those great ventures.
I also feel, especially
having come from SRI,
that we want to create
ventures that really make
a difference, which are
often in areas now that are
deep technology or deeply
difficult to commercialize--
things that relate to medical
devices, clean water, energy,
helping the world in
many different ways.
And researchers and
engineers and technologists
often don't feel that that's an
opportunity for venture capital
and investment.
And I'm here to say
that's not true,
that you can create
great ventures
from those
technologies, as well.
The other point is,
and you'll read it
if you read it in the book
in the first few pages,
this is not about
the narrow segment
of ventures that are usually
software ventures that you
can get out into the market
with $50,000 or less of money,
get some family money
and start pivoting often,
fail fast, fail often,
and get to something.
This is against that model.
You can succeed with that model.
It's not like I'm
trying to say you can't.
But it's not the
kind of model where
if you really want to go
out and really, that's
why the word "really" is
emphasized in the book,
intend to change the world.
That's not the model I would
recommend you start with,
and so we'll be talking
about that model.
The other thing is,
while I'm talking,
I've set aside like 30
minutes or so for presentation
and another 30 for discussion.
But I am a teacher, too, so I
just finished my first class
at Stanford.
I'm teaching the GSB second-year
graduate students there.
So I like questions.
So if any of you feel that
you need to understand,
that would really make
it an engaging time.
And the harder the
question, the better.
First of all, my experience,
though-- why am I here?
One is by SRI, I created the SRI
venture and commercialization
process.
And out of that, we've
created about 70 companies.
And out of those
70 companies, four
have IPO'd, many
had been acquired,
the total market value
is about $25 billion.
I brought back to SRI
about $350 million.
One of the important things
about that, by the way, is it
wasn't just ventures.
It's ventures and
royalty and equity,
and that has brought
in an ongoing stream
of revenue every year, somewhere
between $10 and $40 million
on average per year.
SRI is founded by Stanford.
It also, RCA Labs, where I
came from, was acquired by SRI.
GE actually donated a billion
dollar donation of RCA Labs
to SRI when GE
bought RCA and didn't
know what to do with
consumer electronics.
That's what happened,
and Jack Welch was there.
I was on the merger
team that was
like having arrived on Ellis
Island and being turned back,
but it was the best thing
that happened to us.
2,400 staff members at
SRI, consolidated revenue's
about $500 million.
They're all over the place,
and SRI's now independent.
It became independent around
1970 during the student riots--
not riots, protests.
And so Stanford said let's
make them independent,
and that was a great effect.
This is the bragging chart
that I want to get past
this as quickly as possible.
But SRI has a long history,
and not just an old history,
of succeeding in
commercialization.
Actually, the first mouse--
let me try this little thing
that I bought-- the first
mouse from Doug Engelbart
was invented and
patented at SRI.
After that, it went
to Xerox PARC, where
they did a lot of
the application
development, and after that, to
Apple, obviously, and others.
This is the napkin on which
the internet was designed.
That's the complete
internet at the time.
SRI is in red, receiving
bits from UCLA.
The first login
was "log" and then
it dropped before
"in" could come out.
We do everything which is really
exciting-- malaria, drugs,
new types of neurological and
cancer drugs, Academy Awards,
Emmys.
I was on the one related
to HDTV-- on the team,
I should say.
Those little numbers
on your check we did.
Siri was most recently in
2010 one of our startups
that got acquired.
So it's consistent.
We're building blocks.
This is just a list
of the companies
that we've helped
create, and you
have that kind of
average impact that you
expect from venture capital.
Actually, better
performance than you
might expect from a normal
venture capital firm--
somewhere about between 1 in
10 and 1 in 20 of our startups
are home runs.
Namely, they create 10
to 100 times their value.
To us, many times the startups
are singles and doubles,
meaning they returned their
value back or a little more.
And we've actually never
had a true bankruptcy
where everybody lost everything,
so it's been quite a ride.
And what's really interesting
is unlike other venture models,
we create only three or
four ventures a year.
Like 1,500 projects,
$500 million going
in-- three or four ventures.
But the reason for
that is because
of why I wrote this book.
We only focused on
creating ventures
that could be home runs,
billion-dollar companies,
breakthrough companies
that could really
make a difference in the world.
And similarly, Henry at
Warburg Pincus did the same.
Henry's a great researcher
and he and I together
were at RCA Labs before
we came out here,
before he came to the venture
community and I came out here.
As you can see
materials, biomed,
all of those technologies.
If you had to say the
moral to the story
here about creating breakthrough
companies, it's really here.
If you have achieved
and if you want
to accomplish great things,
great aim, you fix your gaze
and it sometimes
seems impossible,
and you stay consistent.
This is why I have difficulty
with the fail fast, fail
often, pivot often model, and
we'll draw a picture later
if we have questions.
But over time when you're
creating a venture, what
do you iterate on?
What do you iterate on?
In the venture capital world--
sorry, what do you iterate on
and what you don't iterate on
is your core value proposition.
You rarely iterate on your team.
You rarely iterate and
change on whether you're
a consumer or an enterprise
play after you've been funded.
Before you're funded,
anything goes.
Before you take
external money, you
can iterate, decide on
your own venture concept
and really make it work, and
I'll show you how that works.
In terms of the technology
that we helped create companies
from, it really comes
from the Bayh-Dole Act.
Does anybody know Bayh-Dole?
Raise your hands if you know it.
So in the US back in 1980,
Birch Bayh and Bob Dole
passed a law that said if you
do projects for the government
and you're a
nonprofit institution,
such as a university
or a lab, then
you can own all the
commercial rights of anything
you do, any breakthroughs
you achieve.
That is an incredible
war chest of technology
that comes to Stanford,
Berkeley, SRI, all of these.
That is the basis of it.
And the crime of it is we
do breakthrough technology--
our number one customer was
DARPA-- we do breakthrough
technology and then it
may just sit on the shelf
and the real iteration
doesn't occur,
doesn't drive up
the value curve,
and instead we just go to
the next great invention.
So the Bayh-Dole Act is there.
We can own the
commercial rights.
That gives you the incentive
to do commercial success.
And by the way, at
SRI, we gave a third
of what we got
back to employees.
That's one reason SRI
wasn't hollowed out
by the nearby companies
that could easily
recruit all their staff,
because they could have
a portfolio of
stock or of royalty
and continue to stay at SRI.
On creating value
propositions, does everybody
know what a value
proposition is?
Raise your hands.
Believe me, you have to know
if you're starting a venture.
There are four elements,
and in the book
it's repeated multiple times.
If you want to start
a great a venture,
there are four things you need.
One is a great market
problem-- really
a pain point, unless
it's consumer.
In consumer, it's a
different kind of pain point.
In an enterprise, a pain
point for market problem
is customers or companies
have extreme pain,
have some problem they want to
solve, and you can solve it.
So market pain-- a disruptive
and differentiated solution,
disruptive only because
these days if you only
have an incremental solution,
you're not going to win.
Somebody else is going to
apply an incremental solution.
And a great team and a
great value proposition.
We're going to get into that.
This is about
value propositions,
and so this is actually
the SRI process.
It's a mnemonic called NABC.
It's actually not the
full-value proposition.
The book lists that.
I'll give it to you
in a minute on a page.
But a full-value proposition's--
the beginning of a value
proposition, and these
arrows indicate iteration,
starts with customer
and market needs.
It's remarkable in
a technology space,
people don't think
normally that way.
When people have a
great technology,
I've got a great new processing
or a great new bandwidth
or whatever-- that
kind of problem,
they don't think naturally of
what market are they reaching,
what customer are
they reaching, what
pain point are they solving.
That is a crucial element.
So basically everyone
that we worked with
had to start with and iterate
on a customer and market need,
then look for the differentiated
and disruptive solutions--
well, business and technical.
Then try to quantify
the benefits,
and I'll tell you what we
did with Siri in that case,
and then always articulate the
competition and alternative
approaches.
And then iterate again
and again and again.
That's when you're creating
a company, when you really
have the concept, when you're
iterating on the concept.
And so in some sense,
this is crucial to do
and actually
crucial to continue.
But once the funding starts,
you have far less flexibility
because then you have
a lifetime established
by the amount of money
that you've been given
and a runway to get there
and a goal to get there,
and that's why this is
so important to have
ahead of time.
I'm not going to go
through the SRI process
for creating ventures, but
it's one more generally
that's open to any research
institution or lab that
wants to spin out companies--
starting with a concept,
internally funding it,
using external venture
capital support.
We have great friends in
the venture capital world.
And then building a
venture or license.
When I told you earlier we
only do three or four ventures
a year, we probably
do 20 or 30 or 40
licenses that don't meet the
strategy of breakthrough.
So let's go to
the story of Siri.
How many people
here think that Siri
started with we have great
natural language understanding,
we have great speech technology,
we started the original Nuance,
we knew what we were
doing, we had AI,
so we need to figure out
what venture we could have?
How many think so?
Good, very good.
It wasn't.
We knew that there were
certain opportunities that
were created that
were remarkable
that we knew that
the mobile phone had,
and those opportunities had
more power than a supercomputer
10 years earlier.
They were always on,
always connected,
they had more storage and
bandwidth capabilities.
And at the time, only
ringtones and SMS messages
were the dominant apps.
We didn't know what
we wanted to do,
but we knew that we
were on the leading
edge of most every
computing revolution at SRI.
So what are we going to do?
Well, part of it
started by accident.
CALO was started
by the government.
DARPA-- DARPA, our
number one customer.
CALO stands for Cognitive
Assistant that Learns
and Organizes.
That meant an agent.
They were happy.
They liked agent technology,
agent meaning delegate
technology to some software.
We didn't know what the
business was, the model was,
or anything.
But they started a program.
We led it.
SRI was the project.
We had 23 subs from the
who's who of the AI world--
Stanford, Harvard, Carnegie
Mellon, MIT, Berkeley,
you name it.
They're all there.
SRI was the prime and we worked
on CALO, a five-year program,
the largest program in the
history of the US government
in artificial intelligence.
The second inspiration was, and
this came from actually DARPA,
was "MASH."
How many people know "MASH"?
Raise your hands, please.
So do you remember in
"MASH," this guy here,
over here, Radar O'Reilly?
So Radar always know
what the colonel
wanted before the colonel
knew what the colonel wanted.
That was the thing about Radar.
And so DARPA wanted to
create a Radar for you.
What they really
wanted to do was
create an assistant
that would allow you
and give you insight
into your life
and support you in
your life, like Radar
did, to give you an assistant
with real-time knowledge.
It was called
learning in the wild.
Everybody know you could
do AI in large volumes
of massive data, but
learning in the wild
meant you had to
do it in real time
as the person was walking
along, doing their activities,
and all.
And that was what
that program was,
and that was a
great inspiration.
So what I told you
earlier, there's
four things that it takes
to do a great venture.
That's it.
As you leave this
room, you can all
decide these are the
four things you need.
Obviously, it's
hard to do each one,
and the book is
about how to do that.
It's about the market need and
the opportunities, the team.
Breakthrough for Siri started
and happened, actually,
not because of CALO,
not because of DARPA,
but because we finally
found a market pain point.
We were seeking what's the
problem that we could really
solve with a "Radar
O'Reilly" kind of capability.
What's the market
opportunity we could create?
And finally we
realized at the time--
this was 2007, June of 2007--
that mobile phones were
difficult to use to access
web services like OpenTable,
Yelp, hotels.com.
They were all there building
their APIs for the customers
and they were losing 20% of
their customers for every click
that people had to do.
People were not
used to clicking.
They didn't know how
to do that, or at least
they didn't want to.
And so what happened was that
we created the market problem,
finally.
We understood that the problem,
the pain point of the market,
was not clicking, to have
a zero-click solution,
and that's what we created.
That's why we created Siri.
We wanted Siri to give
answers, not links.
We didn't want people to have
to go and then link and click
on the next.
We didn't want Siri
to be a search engine.
We wanted it to be a do
engine, and that was the basis
for the value proposition.
The business function,
the revenue model,
was lead generation.
If we could lead
you to OpenTable
or to any other,
hotels.com or whatever,
they would pay us for that lead.
So it was click per action, and
that was the business model.
And together with that, we
created the basis for Siri.
Now, I'm not going
to go through this.
But in the book,
these are the 11 steps
that you really need to do to
create a venture-fundable value
proposition.
They're beyond NABC,
obviously, but NABC is actually
the core elements of that.
If you could do that,
if you can do your NABC,
you can get started in
what the opportunity is.
It's in the book.
This page is almost
identically in the book.
So then Siri all of
a sudden in 2010,
April-- actually, we launched
the first product in February.
How much time do we
have, by the way?
1:30.
I'm going to be finished soon
so we can all go through it.
In February, 2010, we
launched the company
and get this phone call.
The CEO, Dag Kittlaus, of
Siri-- and I was on the board
as well as being a
co-founder-- the CEO gets
a phone call on his cellphone.
"Hi, this is Steve."
And he says, "Steve who?"
And he says, "Steve Jobs."
And he says, "Sure,"
and he hangs up.
[LAUGHTER]
So then he comes back again.
He calls again and he says hi,
no, really, this is Steve Jobs.
And so Steve called
and talked to the CEO.
He invited the
three founders that
were part of the
team-- I was not,
I was still at SRI running
the ventures activity--
to his house.
And from that point on, there
was a certain honeymoon period
between the founders
and him over a period
of two to four weeks
where the board originally
said do not discuss
any funding activities.
But ultimately, we were invested
in by venture capitalists
and by a team that really want
to make a difference by having
their work go to tens or
hundreds of millions of people.
And the venture
capitalists were offered
an opportunity that would
give them a very fine reward.
We can't tell you what
that was because that's
part of the contract
agreement, that we would never
specify how much that amount
was, and that's what happened.
I sent Steve a note
afterwards saying
you got a great company--
I was on the board--
and I hope that we can work
together in the future.
In his classic way, he
sent me a note back,
very short-- simply, we
won't disappoint you.
Now, you all know that
truthfully Siri on occasion
was and seemed disappointing.
Rarely a person came up to me
and said, I love Siri, period.
It was always I like Siri,
but it's not recognizing me,
or I ask it questions,
and so on and so on.
And of course, you have
Google Now, as well.
But it has made
great progress and it
is being used by
hundreds of millions
of people around the
world and continues
to be in every product.
So that's all about
the story of Siri.
That was chapter one.
The rest of the
chapters are trying
to show you how to
build opportunities
from the great opportunities
that exist today.
There are no greater
opportunities, in my opinion,
than now.
There's globalization,
demographics,
the adversary between, in
particular, cybersecurity,
the growing markets,
particularly in China,
revolutionary technologies.
They're all happening now.
You guys are
probably all involved
in various pieces of this.
This is why I'm
excited to talk to you.
There's breakthroughs
in virtually every area
and advanced by technology.
These, in particular--
microsatellites
that you folks have the
Loon project, but maybe
others in the CubeSats.
They're going to be
circling the world
and basically creating
whole new infrastructure
for wireless carriers.
Autonomous vehicles--
look at what
you've done, something
wonderful in terms
of creating the original
breakthroughs in that space.
Health care devices I'm
particularly involved
in right now.
And when I left SRI, I
began advising as a venture
adviser a few startups.
And in health care
devices, given the fact
that you can sequence
genomes, and not only
your own but the
genomes of the bacteria
or viruses or the tumors, we're
in for a huge breakthrough
in the ability for people
to improve their health
and wellness.
I was really excited
by this because we
helped make this device.
A woman in the Boston
Marathon lost her leg.
She was a dancer.
And 18 months later,
Hugh Herr from MIT,
who also has lost his legs--
he is an MIT professor--
showed what could be done in the
whole new world of prosthetics.
This is just an example,
the tiny example
of what could be done with
robotics and personalized
robotics.
And 18 months later,
this TED-- I'm
going to do a cut
of that TED talk.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
NORMAN WINARSKY: Look
at how beautifully
that leg and the
actuators, which
are driven by her own
muscles, have enabled her
to use her legs again to dance.
This was her first time
that she was dancing.
This kind of robotic
system helping people,
assisting people, is
now within two years.
You've just seen the DARPA
Robotics Challenge recently,
where robots are walking
and preforming activities.
We are also building at
SRI exoskeletons without--
[CHEERING]
[END PLAYBACK]
NORMAN WINARSKY: We're
also building exoskeletons
without the exoskeleton,
so using human bones
as the skeleton.
And we're doing exo-muscles
for people to wear outfits.
This is the world you're in.
Another part of the book
is about the investors,
how the great investors
act and what they look for.
Of course, I hear so many
times venture capitalists,
vulture capitals, whatever,
and then what kind of deal
are they offering.
This book is about the kind
of deal they really offer.
It's not about the
money, and it's not even
about the equity terms.
It's about what kind
of value they offer you
in their networks of friends,
their wisdom and their guidance
in creating and running
the venture, their ability
to help you recruit, and so on.
This is what you use, and
this is what's described.
I'm going to tell you
one thing about talking
to great investors.
If you have a great
venture concept,
there's only three things that--
and these are some of them--
this is Mike Moritz, Vinod
Khosla, Kevin Efrusy at Accel,
Steve Jurvetson,
Gary Morgenthaler.
These are these are all greats.
There are three
things they're always
looking for in
your first venture,
your first presentation to them.
So don't forget
the three things.
That's in the book, but
I'm not telling you.
No, I will.
I will.
The three things
are one, you have
to show them you have a
deeply compelling value
proposition-- deeply
compelling-- I'm
talking about the greats
now-- something that
really is a change the
world value proposition.
Secondly, you have to show them
that you're committed to it.
This is another issue that
I have with the fail fast,
fail often.
You have to show you
have passion for the idea
and you've wanted it, you've
lived it, you want it to happen
and you're going to do
anything 24 hours a day,
seven days a week.
You're going to be there
to make that happen.
That's what they
want to see from you.
And the third thing they're
going to want to see from you
is that you can execute.
You're not there
in pie in the sky.
You're there and
you're telling them
I'm going to be able to
go to the first step.
The analogy that
Vinod Khosla uses
when you're climbing
Mount Everest-- I'm
going to get to a base camp.
I'm going to get there.
I'm going to have
this much money.
I'm going to have this team,
and I'm going to keep it clean
and I'm going to
keep it aggressive.
Those kind of things
are in the three things
that you need to achieve.
There's also five meetings
that are listed in the book.
That's the first meeting.
You achieve that.
In my principle, Woody Allen
says 80% of life is showing up.
If you achieve that--
the Norman Winarsky
principle is 20% of life
is knowing when to leave.
So you got to go and you've
achieved what you did.
Teams and execution--
it's obvious, again.
We talk about how to
build teams and when
to build teams and the
ego related to teams.
Teams-- you could be a
founder, you could be a CEO.
You don't need to be both.
You want to bring a team
in and keep your money
as lean as possible and so on.
This is how to execute
a breakthrough venture,
and it's all in the book--
choosing the CEO, the founders,
choosing the right investors,
and maintaining the value
proposition.
The mistakes that I've
seen and Henry's seen over
these dozens of companies--
some are not avoidable,
like the world
changes, the government
changes the standard, whatever.
But some of them are avoidable,
and these are the five
we described in the book.
So fail to know your customer--
I started a company that I
thought was the best possible
company you could imagine.
In terms of communications,
it was going
to do mobile ad hoc networking.
Firefighters and
people like that
were going to be able to use
it with the internet running up
the stairs with them
instead of leaving them
without communications,
as what happened in 9/11.
That company failed
because the CEO really
wasn't deeply knowledgeable.
It was a great idea, but the
CEO nor the VP of marketing
were deeply knowledgeable
about that community
of the firefighters and
the emergency responders,
and so the book describes
how that failed.
Keep the wrong CEO-- this is a
challenge in business schools
all over the world.
People still think is it
the horse or the rider?
What happens if you
have a great CEO?
Which is more important, a
great CEO or a great company?
I'm going to leave it
to you to read the book,
but I'll tell you
we come out on CEO,
and many of the business
schools in LA come out on it's
the great company.
Mismanaged finances--
that means there's
obvious ways you can do that.
You hire too much, you have
too much engineering services,
too many human labor
components, and so on.
Becoming overconfident
is a remarkable failure.
It's when you become
blind to your competitors.
You're doing so well
that you're just not
even open to
considering competitors.
You might think of Nokia
in that space, for example.
And fail to anticipate future
industry developments--
a lot of that is in
the book, as well.
So I want to keep going
on because we're near done
and I want you to ask questions.
Finally, this book is
about how to maintain
an ambidextrous organization.
That's a word that's
actually not in the book,
but it's the word
that Stanford uses.
It's an organization that's both
good at building and continuing
their existing products and
services, as well as innovating
and create breakthrough
products and services.
That's the left
hand, the right hand.
That's the ambidextrous.
Turns out that the
average lifespan
of a company at the turn of
the century, around there,
was 67 years-- a
company in the Standard
& Poor 500, the top 500
companies in the United States.
What do you think the
average lifespan of a company
is around now?
Guess, please.
AUDIENCE: 14 years.
NORMAN WINARSKY: 14 years.
So if you're in the top 500
companies in the United States,
you're in danger.
You're going to be broken up
or bought, one way or another.
Look at Kodak, Polaroid,
or Oracle, Sun.
You can just keep
going on and on.
So the book ends
with an approach
to ensuring the future, how
we went about it, what we've
done to do that, and what
it takes to create centers
of innovation.
You have Google X here,
which I think is actually
a great model for continuing.
I don't know the inner
details about how you do it
because there has to be a lot
about financial independence,
it has to be
top-level CEO support,
it has to be new metrics
and new measurements that
are not related to the
revenue that so dwarfs it
in the beginning.
And so there has to be a whole
lot to creating and building
a company and maintaining
it in the 21st century.
So thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
Any questions?
AUDIENCE: Hi, I have
a quick question.
Let's say I have a
breakthrough idea.
At which point,
like at what stage,
does it make sense to engage
venture capitalists like SRI?
Like what's the MVP [INAUDIBLE]?
NORMAN WINARSKY: So if you
have a breakthrough idea, what
they're going to look
for-- and by the way,
that's where your
iteration occurs.
Do I have the right market?
I have my market.
Well, no, it's too
broad a market.
Do I have the right solution?
No, the technology solution
only works for a narrower space,
or whatever.
And then finally,
do I have a team?
A venture capitalist
will not normally
consider strongly
something which
is called heavy
lifting, where they
have to go help recruit the
CEO, where they have to help
go recruit the key people.
So there needs to
be a core team.
They don't have to be
working for the company,
but they have to
have come together
and said we're going
to be founder, CEO.
This is where the technology
is going to come from.
Here is our value
proposition, and here
is the beginnings of the
value proposition, at least.
Here's the competition.
Here's all these elements.
Here's the risks.
And then you go
in front of them.
Now, these days, you can
also go in front of angels,
as wealthy individuals,
instead of venture capitalists.
You could start
with wealthy angels.
The truth is I would still go
to great venture capitalists
because they'll watch
you, they'll track you,
they'll see how you're doing.
Sometimes they'll fund you.
Somebody like a Vinod Khosla
likes to come in very early.
He can either do seed
or A. Mike Moritz
believes in people like you.
He believes in people that
have breakthrough ideas who
are energized and passionate
and it's their idea
and they want to make it happen.
So get the four elements
of your company in mind--
your team, core team-- you only
need three or four people who
are going to come together--
your market problem and value
proposition, your
differentiated technology,
and you better understand
your competition,
and the goal is to
get to an A round.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So you
don't need to have
an established running business?
NORMAN WINARSKY: Oh, no.
AUDIENCE: Like people
can just still,
let's say, have
their [INAUDIBLE]?
NORMAN WINARSKY: No.
That's a huge mistake
people make, by the way,
against their own selves.
When we started Siri, there
wasn't a running product.
The purpose of a venture
capitalist or any other funder
is to build the commercial
product and to help it scale.
If you tried building the
product on your own beforehand,
first of all, you won't succeed
very well because it'll usually
have too little money.
And secondly, you won't
have done it fast enough
or had sufficient resources.
So definitely they
will love the fact
that you're going
to build the product
or service with their money.
You need, and that was item
number 11 in that deck,
but you'll never get venture
funding-- I should never say
never, that's a terrible thing.
You'll never get--
no, I did it again.
[LAUGHTER]
You're unlikely to get venture
funding with a PowerPoint
alone.
That world's over,
as far as I know,
unless you're a superstar.
You need a PowerPoint,
a team, and you
need a demo or a proof
of concept of some form,
but not the whole product.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
Thanks for coming.
So just as a context I'm not
very well read in the area.
I'm just a little bit
curious and stuff.
But from the little
I read when you
talk about the dimensions
is the time [INAUDIBLE]
the team, the business
plan, and the idea.
So one of the articles
I read kind of
emphasizes a more underlooked,
I think, concept of timing.
So I want to see if you can
comment about the things
that you have seen
succeed or fail
because my perspective
is we want to believe
that a lot depends on
us, how good we are,
how much experience.
But maybe the reality is a
lot like what's the timing
and do we get some element
of [INAUDIBLE] there?
NORMAN WINARSKY: Thank
you for that question.
First of all, it's just as bad
to be too early or to late.
And just like the stock market,
you can't time too well.
So what you have to do
is feel-- it depends
on what your problem is.
Is the market problem
painful enough?
That's one thing
I always look for.
Is the market problem
so painful-- in the case
of medical, it's obvious.
Something like a disease,
like cancer or something,
you can literally
quantify it very easily.
Is the market problem so painful
that it's not going to go away?
So that helps you
with the timing.
The second is your solution.
Is your technology solution
mature or are you really
asking to do more research?
I do not support more
technology research.
In each of these programs
that we've built,
there have been
hundreds of millions,
if not billions of dollars, by
the government funding-- that's
why I said it was so important--
hundreds of millions of dollars
towards building the technology.
Do not ask a venture
capitalist to come and help
you build more technology.
That's not going to happen.
Go get your next government
contract or commercial contract
or whatever.
And so that part
of timing is make
sure your technology, if
it's technology, is mature.
Or if it's a
business model, make
sure the business model is
implementable, and make sure
there's a base camp.
So the final thing about
timing is this idea
of Mount Everest and base camp.
Did anybody read
the note on this?
I'll explain it briefly.
I'll explain it.
It is true that
you shouldn't try
to climb Mount
Everest all at once
and somehow scale what you're
trying to achieve all at once.
Nobody would believe you.
It's like boiling the ocean.
It's really Geoffrey
Moore "Crossing the Chasm"
kind of thing.
You need to start with something
that you think is achievable.
And every time you do a
round, and this book describes
the rounds-- the A round,
the B round, the C Round,
and so forth-- every
time you do a round,
it's not for the money.
You're doing a round to
get the next achievement.
What you wanted to
achieve with-- you're
going to first get the product.
That'll probably be
round A, and build
revenue might be round B. Build
profitability might be round C.
Scale is round D, and so forth.
Now, of course
those are different,
but that's how timing helps you.
But yes, a venture capitalist--
each one of those rounds
should never be
more than 18 months.
No venture capitalist
in general,
unless it's medical
devices or health care,
would expect to have their
money last more than around 18
to 24 months.
That's a good question.
Other question?
AUDIENCE: What suggestions do
you have for future-proofing
your vision, especially
if you're not
planning to go and fail
safe and fail fast?
NORMAN WINARSKY: Wait, say--
AUDIENCE: Future-proof your
vision, and I'll explain--
NORMAN WINARSKY: My vision?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, or if you have
a venture and you have an idea,
you see a market need and you
have a vision and technology
how to solve it.
NORMAN WINARSKY: When you say
you, are you meaning you or me?
AUDIENCE: I'm just
referring to like a person.
And there can be, I
think, opportunity
to fail on both sides, right?
NORMAN WINARSKY: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: One, you may create
a solution which by the time
you actually implement
it may be not the best
way to solve this problem,
even though it does.
Or you may create a solution
where the market isn't ready,
and there have been
examples, I think-- well,
we can take even
one of the examples
we did at Google in
Google X, Google Glass,
where we went and learned a
lot, but we realized maybe
it wasn't the right solution.
NORMAN WINARSKY: Right, right.
AUDIENCE: So without
going and trying
to learn as much as possible
and fail, how do you actually
protect yourself from working
too long on the solution which
may not be the right one?
NORMAN WINARSKY:
So a couple things.
One is a venture
capitalist-- again,
the good ones-- would
not have allowed
a long period of time for the
first proof points to be there.
So you would have had to
form early proof points.
And maybe the early
proof points would
have been where you
are right now, which
is, I think, quite a wonderful
application at Google
Glass with doctors using
it, people like that.
That might have been an early
proof point, as people started
using it and experiencing it.
Other ways that you can--
you're getting into timing,
in other words.
You're saying how do we know
when there's an opportunity
and how long should
we work on it, right?
Everything has to be
broken up into milestones
within 18-month chunks.
And as you're moving
along, if you're not
achieving those
milestones, you're
going to start
finding difficulty
to continue the funding.
AUDIENCE: So one of the
things you emphasize
was finding the right team.
NORMAN WINARSKY: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Bringing the
right team to the venture.
NORMAN WINARSKY: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I know a lot of us
probably have a great idea,
but lack the help to get
that idea off the ground.
NORMAN WINARSKY: Right.
AUDIENCE: So what do you
do in that kind of case?
What do you suggest
for somebody like that?
NORMAN WINARSKY: So Let me
tell you how we did that,
and we had that problem
every single time.
When you're in a research lab
like SRI with 2,400 people,
most of the people
are researchers.
That's sort of a tautology.
And so how do you get the team?
What we did is
the first thing we
did was build the
value proposition, just
like we talked about.
You can do that with
your internal team
as well as you can.
You're really not a domain
expert usually in the market.
You're not an executive
yet, but you do that.
Once you have that, you use
your own network or venture
capitalists will help you.
They're not funding you.
They'll just give you insight.
You start looking for
the CEO of your dreams
or the VP of product or the
VP of marketing or the like.
Don't bring them on.
You don't need to.
Just get the gang together.
We're going to save
the orphanage now,
"The Blues Brothers."
So get the gang together
and then iterate
again on the value proposition
till you get something solid.
Then you have the team, you
have the value proposition.
You still have the problem
with intellectual property
if it's a technology company.
If it's a business company,
it's a little different.
And so if it's
intellectual property,
you'll probably want to
know who has the patents
or who can do what,
or can you get it
from Stanford or whatever.
And so that's really
how you do it.
You can build.
If you've got somebody
that's both the founder
and a CEO like Larry and Sergey
kind of people, god bless,
go ahead.
But if you don't, that doesn't
mean you can't start this.
You absolutely can because
those kind of people
are looking for these
kind of opportunities.
I really enjoyed it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]